pretty disgusting repulsive whatever
adjective you can come up with the
monster who shot these two
officers still at large as you just
heard a hundred thousand dollar reward
for information on the gunman
the county sheriff is now challenging as
just reported nba star lebron james to
match that reward
joining us now with more is l.a county
sheriff
himself alex villanueva is with us sir
first of all
i watched your very emotional press
conference
the other night our thoughts and prayers
are with your entire
team and these officers in particular
any
any new updates you have they're in
stable condition we expect to survive do
we know if there's going to be long-term
damage to any of them
that the question still has to be
answered they're still in intensive care
and uh well unfortunately
it's going to take a while to have a uh
the rehabilitation the recovery process
and to gain full control
of their extremities and we're just
going to continue praying for them we're
going to support them and hopefully
they'll be able to make that
complete recovery in new york city the
mayor there comrade de blasio cut the
budget by 1 billion dollars 150 million
cut from the lapd more importantly
sheriff
uh we have a vice presidential candidate
uh
that actually praised that cut to police
officers number one
then we have a presidential candidate
who said police become the enemy
and said yeah of course we should
redirect funds away from the police
uh then we've heard i barely mentioned
any of the violence at the dnc i think
it was mentioned like twice in passing
it's been happening for well over a
hundred days i'll go through the list of
how many officers have been
murdered in the in this time period your
reaction
to this in terms of a leadership
position and we'll play the rhetoric of
of top politicians
bashing police on almost on a daily
basis i want your reaction to that
all right what i can say is that
i don't support any politician any
elected leader any
anyone who is an influencer in society
has an obligation to maintain law and
order and to support law and order
and i've heard some things from elected
leaders particularly at the local level
that's just astonishing
and they're just fanning the flames
pouring gas on a fire
and they're not bringing people together
they're further dividing people and it's
reprehensible
and uh this is uh i won't say this is
the outcome of that however they're
contributing to the narrative
that they're always going to be that one
person in the crowd that's going to take
them at face value
and they're going to they're deciding
taking dependent action on that so
people need to be responsible because
words have consequences
and this is a prime example of that well
sheriff let me ask you more directly
we've seen night after night a hundred
plus days
city after city molotov cocktails
uh precincts commandeered by
anarchists uh we've got sticks and
and cops pelted with bricks and rocks
and frozen water bottles stabbed shot
hit with canes and hockey sticks
43 officers murdered in the line of duty
and thousands have been injured but one
party in this country is denied they
said oh no that's a myth
how do you have a convention and not
talk about this how is it
you know barely a good word only under
political pressure
do they finally speak out a little too
little and a little too late from my
mind sir and i do hold them accountable
for their rhetoric
well we got to go by facts and not by
emotion it's really
easy to manipulate emotion it's kind of
hard to manipulate facts
in this nation average once a week
there's a cop killed in the line of duty
by the felony actions of a suspect once
a week
so i know there's a narrative that
people trying to push out that there's a
george floyd
happening in every single department
across the entire nation
that is absolutely false irresponsible
and
obviously it leaves the bad outcomes
that encourages the mob mentality
people trying to storm precincts and uh
i think law enforcement agencies
throughout the nation need to
one is defend uh their
their precincts their police stations
act responsibly obviously with the
public
and work in hand with the community and
we got to hold everyone accountable and
personal accountability is also
important because the
the mantra everywhere is accountability
accountability about law enforcement
but somehow it gets lost in the shuffle
accountability i'd like to know a more
about your challenge to lebron but
i make a distinction there were peaceful
protesters chanting black lives matter
separate and apart from the group black
lives matter that's the group we have on
videotape chanting what do we want dead
cops when we want them now
if you can quickly respond to us that is
very true i had 20 000
protesters right outside my building
right here in downtown only a few months
ago
exercising their first amendment right
and we were there to defend their
exercising their first amendment right
but when they show up at south la
station arm like they're going to play
nfl football as a linebacker they're not
a peaceful protester let's end that
nonsense right now
anybody's got helmet goggles pads
shields
uh frozen water bottles you know
fireworks mortars and all these things
they're there to do damage and then try
to
instill or promote anarchy and we're not
going to support that anyway
let's see if lebron takes your challenge
sheriff our prayers are with the
the two officers in the hospital tonight
fighting for their lives